megan the duchess of sussex is telling
stories about her life as a mother and
her marriage to prince harry in a new
podcast on spotify the first episode of
archetypes features an interview with
megan's friend their very good friends
serena williams it's her first in-depth
interview since announcing her plans to
retire from tennis the two women discuss
everything from their careers to
motherhood including a brush with danger
it was just minutes after this 2019
speech in south africa that meghan
markle says she and prince harry learned
about a frightening incident involving
their son archie who was traveling with
them at the time we finish the
engagement we get in the car and they
say there's been a fire at the residence
what
there's been a fire
in the baby's room what
megan shared the story with serena
williams during her podcast archetypes
the duchess said the baby was thankfully
with his nanny at the time her instinct
was like let me just bring him with me
before i put him down in that amount of
time that she went downstairs
the heater
in the nursery caught on fire
there was no smoke detector
someone happened to just smell smoke
down the hallway went in fire
extinguished he was supposed to be
sleeping in there despite the close call
megan says she and prince harry still
had to carry on with their royal duties
everyone's in tears everyone's shaken
and what do we have to do
go out and do another official
engagement i said this doesn't make any
sense can you just how did you not bring
him i was like can you just tell people
what happened
and so much i think optically
the focus ends up being on how it looks
instead of how it feels
throughout the conversation both megan
and williams talk about the challenges
of motherhood williams recalled playing
a match at the 2018 french open after
being up all night with her daughter who
had a broken wrist
i somehow managed to
win but i was so emotionally spent and
just like so emotionally drained that it
was
it was crazy and
you know and then like every night after
that i just was with her the whole time
and was like you're gonna be with me and
i just took a lot on but
moms do a lot people should expect the
real me in this the 12 episode podcast
explores female stereotypes with this
episode centering on the word ambitious
i don't
ever remember
personally feeling the negative
connotation behind the word ambitious
until i started dating my now husband
and um
[Music]
apparently ambition is a
terrible terrible thing
for a woman that is according to some
that feeling was part of megan's
decision to speak with williams the
23-time grand slam champion recently
announced her retirement from
professional tennis in a vogue magazine
article i was just sitting
in the hotel at the desk just typing and
deleting and typing and thinking and
then crying and
sitting at my computer and
tears streaming down my face as i'm
writing
these words and going back on these
memories and it was just like
god it was it was really hard now the
tennis legend says she's looking forward
to focusing on what she considers her
best role that of mom
you know obviously i'm retiring
professionally but it's also an
evolution i'm i'm doing more business
things and i really want to
expand my family and you know i've been
putting it off for so long and as a
woman there's only so
so long you can put that off
i love listening to icons talk uh jamie
you have a question forgive me for not
grasping the idea why
being ambitious is bad for a woman well
i think you know as a woman when you're
in the room i think if a guy
has an idea or goes forward and or is
even upset about something or is trying
to right a wrong of another co-worker or
something they're ambitious and they're
climbing the ladder if i as a woman do
that i'm looked at as somebody who's you
know a problem you need to be nice calm
down
and i think it's that idea you know and
a lot of women are people pleasers and
you kind of get into that role of okay
i'll just keep my head down i'll do the
job
you know that i'm i'm sent here to do
but i don't want to push too far i don't
want to say too much i don't want to be
too angry right um you know and come off
in a certain way sometimes you use
different words for it right like
ambitious is a man and pushy is the
cushy yes that's i've heard that but
she's passionate about what he does you
see that a lot in sports as well he's
just i love an ambitious woman you know
exactly an ambitious woman
there's nothing wrong with that in my
eyes but i hear what you're saying
though for sure i appreciate that and we
need guys to feel that way